あー本日は純社長です皆さんカーネロライフ作ったことありますでしょうか
僕はないですべ取るとか8かを作ったことなんですけどもちゃんとあの硬いあのこれ
このタイプのやつをまずどうやって作るかされ文字通りよくわかんないですよねただ
レトルトカレーじゃない華麗て
ないとかなんか人参とか玉ねぎとか入ってないんですよ作ったことないからわかんない
けど俺ねこれくらいのクッキーみたいですねって言えば彼がし作っていくわけなんだ
けどもねえって何か無限だと思うんですよ具材各節いろいろあるじゃないですか基本的
には肉たまねぎじゃがいもにんじんは入れると思うんですけどもそれだけじゃなくて
らっしゃらないかでとまぁこいつと言ったらトッピングあるじゃんつまり
なんでもいいんですあれの中身ってあるでコンペたくさんの拍手や具材準備しました
なんだそれが思いますカレー月に何年を入れたお安くなるんだったら何でも入れて
みようということでちょっと俺が個人的に入れてみたいなと思うものをたくさん買って
みましたいってここにならず種類あるんですけども映像の中でくださいもしで持ってき
て走ってちょうど100周年チェックしメールもの彼に打ち込んで今まで皆さんが食べ
たこと
ないような素敵な味のカリーライス作ってみたいと思いますぞうっ
では早速作っていくよまあ作っていくといっても遊んて何もわかんないんですけども
とりあえず食べ詰所どれどれ it まずイタメルって書いてありますね
何を言ったメディアだものはないんでいたベル工程を省きます水おいでに後部へここで
ポイントなんですけどもなんかめちゃくちゃたくさん入れるんです100種類もの
飲み物食べ物ほ景物
液体入れるとかねえじゃなく何故この世性があるんですかでたくさん作りたいと思い
ます一応のバーモンドカレー中に性意味なんですけども
昭和館なかったにそれぞれ60人6済みしました
これで100種類もの具材とかだから各雪の日でもカレーの根本的な汗分かるとかない
と思うんで問題はなくてカレーができると思いますそれ1400ml 水をいるって
書いてあったりとでます
この水の量で来れるなんですよあと4つもあるんでもっと入れますまず薄まっちゃうと
そんなにカレーじゃなくなったんであくまで皆さん主役は華麗で100種類入れると
いっても必ずカレーの元気が止めなければいけません
ラスト1本打ちたいところですけども水なんで意地でても味に変化はねぇナンバーは
コーラですこれ州にありたって思っちゃうよねコーラおいしいねカレーの音根本的な味
がすごいまろやかじゃないかなと思うんですよ
なぁやべ方位ヴィッツ幹部疲れやは簡単席でびっくりしたを痛める省いたんで今水入れ
ました
熱心で解かれる打ち込んで具材れ完成ですはい私どもで駆動しまーすメッツ簡単で
こんなの秒でで急いけど大丈夫ですか
はいこれでは水火を通したらこれ胴体ビーム入れていけばいいんだろちょっとずつ入れ
ていきますかポッカ100レモンまあこれずに中でもう風にが出たらいいかなきゃって
ことですね
鍵ヨイショ水あめのハワイアンブラウンはこれ結局合わせ的なとかあると思いますね
これ甘口なんであなたが一つか恋愛探したいと思ってですよねここからちょっと具材を
入れていきましょう upon
そんな異例的でもダメだと思ってなら1カケられないいただきましょうバナーなぁおっ
かる的なカレーには入ってるような気もしますが
しっかり連れて行きましょう
やばい待ってああああこんなに出てきてもダメだと思うんだよまんだらけちゃうん
足付程度に入ってればいいかなと思います鯉 follow ん q 8も栄養満点な
んで入れて間違いはないでしょ
多分え壁屋根がちょっと夏野菜カレーっぽくなっちゃったんだけど野菜大事ですからね
さすがに入れちゃうよアプリ区八王
以下同文まってなんか唯一の野菜の寄付はしてきたこれたぶりがお前 g 可動部痛
suica
夏を先取りしますねほんとによるエースいいかなんで俺スイカ割りでしか聞いたこと
ないがわからないよ
ッパいけそううわあああっどうやっていれるこれしてもらったんけど真ん中の一番多い
そうな所キュッっとんあの焦っ
ウッさんのこと切れましたいやーきっと良い編みを引き出してくれると思いますさあ
結構沸騰してきました
今のところはゲテモノ料理ですが安心してくださいここからバーモンドカレーのルーを
48多分入れて行きたいと思いますういるところない
えっ
はすぎでな症状してるこれでいいんだろうかああ
よくこんなに入れたが降って跳ね返る所にこんなのいれんだー
古いで終わりました48人分ですはいなんかグズグズに混んでるで多分これであって気
がしますそれでルート切るのを待つっぽいですねサーというわけでカレーが溶けてる間
にどんどんいろんな各社寺具材入れていきましょうまずはこちらから文書でもうこれは
簡単でしょもう
結局彼っていうのは身体なんで本番のかない子なんでしょ往診料を入れて毎週な感じ
ちゃいけないと
ます
ポケカゴメソまあ彼にはよく入ると思います総帥がいつありたんじゃないでしょうか
マヨネーチェッカーでとマイルドな風味を出しても章イッチャ k ちゃんやっぱ
トマトカーを出す痛いですねから指すぎだよ
バッターから澪ちょっと聞かずにいたいところであります婚約前にアッパーを一瞬で
溶けると思ってなんかいい感じの味のテイストになればいいなって感じです
こんな風にグレープあこんなことで応援ツアー
こんなことでまっかっあーらのダウンみなさーん釣りことないどっからどんどんもっと
味付けして組んで本格的な金に近づけていきましょうかにかま
生温い風シーフード噛んでればなって思ってますね
うさ立中根北出てきていい感じなんでしょ
おいブラックペッパーごはんちょっと立の当てつけしていきたいところがあります
ガーリックこれもソウル米カレーパンなーんで華麗にカレーバーガー入れてるんだって
話がいますけど
またをこの中ハワイアン館でたらいいなぐらいの感じですメリットファースていいや何
か色にてるからなんとなく買ってみました歌だ天海が出ていいと思うよねプルコギいい
や
よくわかんないけどこういう韓国の間でもたして行ったほうが長生きするで言ってき
ます
経ち2乳魔送球目ですけどキムチとカレーとの相性に普通にありだと思います下げる
チーク家具とチーズでて相性いいんで個人的には全然アリだと思いますけどね
スパイスさあ普通にカレー専用なんでこれまでおいしくなると思います森永練乳ミルク
水着さあ求めていく
果汁グミブドウ編み調整
家族3市神長って風組あオレンジとコーン編みちょ
ホワイト橋まあのクリーミーかが出たらいいなと思ってます上げたまあ何で買ったん
でしょ
スライスにんにくちゃごはんですよ福浦俺本当は電池しなきゃいけな奴なんですけど
そんな彼もあったかいからいいからって
有楽サンダーちょっと切れますね鹿部エクセラー
長崎かって
は
アルフォートちょっと甘くしすぎた路線をそういう
そいじゃあ一本満足
一本満足バーだとチョコベビーだーっ chocole
情報はでも高くジャズに入れて聞いたことありますけどアイドルで50種類れました
いやそんなが悪くない気がしますけどね new 的にはパットに別にそんな普通の
カレー見えると思うんですけど見てマシュマロとかも時出来てるですよこれ
がんばってくもっちろんあと50床をやるんですけどもなんとかギリでも抱いて
美味しいような気がするんで
移動作業のかで作りたいと思いますどんどん行きましょうダークホワイトチョコエッグ
ガーナチョコライフへガーナミルクチョコメイクアイチューンアップハイチェスト
パールイハイっちゃドレイク
水をめっちゃ前の入れすぎた気がするんですよ大丈夫だろうこれ
入らないよほいまあ込
いい国だしてくると味付けかねえカレーに金を出すことによってアークないすぎた
カレーを戻せなくてですあっち目
また上がっちゃうフェスそうすっごくはなくなっちゃうよこれは入りすぎたしもう
バター豚肉絶対先に出るべきだったら完全に準備した
メンター行っ東金っていうのがあるじゃに相性っていいと思っ
出しました顔がもうを迎えられてるものがある
ライダー風って合うんだろあっちヨーグルトも安い裸体彼要素を含んで言う焼きそばは
彼らじゃなくなってくるレモンチーズ
手帳ケース9ポッパーねちょっと電池の魂集めて梅干し空
福神漬絶対今いる戦力じゃないよだろう
あっその全員半白スモッグできるのでなんですレトルトカレーそれ言っているてみよう
カレーに彼を入れてるっていう新しい証拠です後窓ねぇ勝手クリコ
わかればまずやりたい放題する本当にヤバいすぺレーター
アルコール96%でぞうれっしゃ程度にねちょっと容器もチョッパーしたい俺もう1本
目4ボーダーってばカップバニラ
えピザポテト等
のいって名クリーム中これは俺も夢はからじゃあのもと
ドライカレーの素様子よしおずさあこれで90種類で終わりましたら私知ってるんです
よインドのカレーとかもものすごい量はの方神領町3-入ってるんですよやってること
大して変わんないんでマジで何か
ああああああ
ちょっと不安ですが
ゾーブだと思います残り10周に入れていきましょうある1
ウィンナーあっちょっという
たなくクリームたりおいしいと思うんだよあー
レバーな大野同じ考えと思うらいあらッカット等とこれ美味そうな溝
住んでメスって何だろうラストですシュークリーム
というわけで完成しました
car
客する位の調味料各社具材数字をかき集めて最強のカレーが完成しました
宿でも撮ろうかなぁもうテレビはですねしっかりと入れていきましょうか
はいというわけでメッツ時間かかりましたため2時間ぐらい作ってるんですけども褒め
ていただきたいまず100種類もものを集めたことを褒めていただきたいもうめっちゃ
演歌深夜にスーパー行ってめっちゃ迷って100種類を選んだりして結局ならず種類
しか見つからなかったんですけどそこからは家にあることはコンビニとか言ってなんと
かさんと処理+して100種類集めることができました必要割と
アリなのかなというものをまとめたんでそんなに悪くない味だとは思うんですけども
所々やっぱの悪2ってが入ったりしてるんでそこが投票に行くかどうかが凄い気になっ
ておりますこれで美味しかったらもうカレーはどんな味付けしても美味しいということ
を証明になると思うのでどんな味に仕上がっているのでしょうか
早速盛り付けて行きましょう
[音楽]
愛的でこれですねー100種類もの食材を混ぜた伝説のカレーライス
カレー缶がまあ良くも悪くもないですケミカルの朝の匂いがしますね
大丈夫9 f なぜなら僕は
僕が好きな食べ物ばっかり入れたわけですから後彼に合いそうなものそれを台無しに
することはないと思うんさせこれは早速食べてみたいと思います
やりますねいい風をに行くとウィンダーが乗ってるんでここらへんとかそこにいいん
じゃないでしょうか
いただきます
ています
4敗
[音楽]
bl
いやー全然ね食べてるときはすごい
普通のかねえなんですよまあまずいとがないとまずいとかなんですけど普通のカレーで
おいおいしーこないですねバー今度金来た方がいいと思います
不味くはないけど美味しくもないと言いますかやー多分で甘いの入れすぎた気がします
ねさすがに上手く表現できないですけど口の中に入った1発目のなんかの投手たち
がめちゃくちゃ何か甘いん
あーんだろくれないかじゃないでね全然食えないことはないですけど色々あってる時で
よくわかんないや
全然まずいとかはないんですけどもまぁあんまりお勧めしないですね普通に食べた方が
断然美味しいと思います
[音楽]
文等